وسوف نوضح فقط
أنه بسبب وقوع هذا الزلزال،
كانت هناك مباني في طوكيو كانت
تهز البلاد وقد تعرضت
لضائقة بسبب ذلك بقدر ما
نفهم أنه لم يكن له أي تأثير على الإطلاق
على هذا الوضع، وهذا أمر
مستقل على حد علمنا لأنه
انتهى الزلزال أه
ولم تكن هناك توابع أه كانت
ملحوظة بالتأكيد من هنا على بعد حوالي 20
دقيقة من المكان أه وقع هذا الحادث
في مطار هانا أم ولكن مرة أخرى
كنت مسافرًا إلى هنا وصلت قبل بضع
ساعات فقط لتغطية الزلزال الذي
كانت قصتنا أم وبعد ذلك وفي حد
ذاته حزين جدًا بالنسبة لليابان بعد
ساعات فقط من رنين العام الجديد
لتتعرض لهذا الزلزال الهائل
ويرتفع عدد القتلى
كل ساعة هنا ولكن الآن اه
هذه القصة التي الصور
مروعة ولكن العنوان الرئيسي مذهل
أن 367 شخصًا و12 من أفراد الطاقم
خرجوا من هذا أحياء لقد
نجوا من هذا وأه
مقاطع الفيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي مازلنا نعمل على
التحقق منها وتوضيحها لكم ولكننا  كنت
أشاهدهم الركاب الذين كانوا
داخل الطائرة وهم يطلقون النار على
نوافذهم، كان بإمكانك رؤية المحرك وهو
يحترق، وكان بإمكانك رؤية المحرك وهو يحتك
بالأرض، ويمكنك سماعه في المقصورة
على الأقل من مقطع الفيديو الوحيد الذي
شاهدته للتو بصوت عالٍ ليس مفاجئًا
كان من الممكن سماع قدر من الذعر تقريبًا
أن الناس كانوا مذهولين ولكن قد
يتخيل المرء أن الناس كانوا في
غاية التركيز إذا تمكنوا جميعًا من
النزول من تلك الطائرة بأمان لأنه
كان من الممكن أن يكون أمامهم بضع ثوانٍ فقط،
وكانت هذه رحلة الخطوط الجوية اليابانية  516 اه
من سابورو إلى طوكيو، سابورو هي منطقة جذب سياحي آه،
وهذا هو موسم الذروة الخاص بهم
آه وبالطبع هذه عطلة
نهاية الأسبوع، لذا كانت الطائرة مكتظة وكانت
رحلة كاملة عندما تتحدث عن ما
يقرب من 400 شخص أو نحو ذلك على متن الطائرة  هذه طائرة
إيرباص 350، وهي طائرة مشهورة جدًا، وهي
طائرة ذات محركين
تستخدمها العديد من شركات الطيران المختلفة.
الخطوط الجوية اليابانية لديها مجموعة منها، ولديها
سجل سلامة جيد جدًا، كما
تعلمون جميعًا، الخطوط الجوية اليابانية تفعل
واحدة  الشيء الذي كانوا يقولونه في
الأخبار هنا هو أن هذا قد يكون
أول حادث معروف من نوعه في
مطار في اليابان، وما زلنا نحاول
التحقق من ذلك ولكن هذه دولة
لديها قطارات فائقة السرعة ولم يسبق
لها مثيل  حالة وفاة في قطاراتهم السريعة
لأنهم حريصون جدًا على
السلامة وينطبق الشيء نفسه على
الخطوط الجوية، أعني أنه يجب عليك مشاهدة
مقاطع الفيديو التي يقومون بتشغيلها لك عندما
تكون على وشك الإقلاع عندما تكون على متن
أي شركة طيران يابانية.  مفصلة
ومحددة للغاية حول الإجراءات التي
يتعين عليك اتباعها ومن الواضح أن
ممارسات أفراد الطاقم أه أن
الاهتمام بالتفاصيل أه قد أتى بثماره في
هذه الحالة حيث تمكن جميع هؤلاء الركاب من
النزول من أحد
الركاب الذين ينشرون على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي  قال
في أحد منشوراته على X المعروف سابقًا
باسم Twitter إنه كان يعتقد أنه
سيموت وعندما تنظر إلى هذه الصور
عندما بدأت الصور تظهر لأول مرة
أه سيفترض المرء أن هذا
موقف مأساوي مروع حقًا ومع ذلك
فهو بالتأكيد  صورة درامية للغاية
ولكنها نتيجة لا تصدق على الإطلاق
هنا لجميع الأشخاص الذين كانوا على متن تلك
الطائرة وهم ينزلون من بيانكا على قيد الحياة،
هذه أخبار جيدة مثل الارتياح كما
تقول هل سيشاهد جمهورنا الآن
تلك الصور الحية من طوكيو من
المطار حيث نحن  أستطيع أن أرى أن
الطائرة التي اشتعلت فيها النيران كانت
تصف أيضًا جميع
الركاب البالغ عددهم 367 راكبًا وأفراد الطاقم الـ 12 الذين تمكنوا من
الهروب من الطائرة في ما يعد مجرد
صورة مذهلة هنا للنيران،
والحمد لله أن الناس خرجوا أحياء
لأنه يبدو أكثر
خطورة بكثير من  أن مجرد مشاهدته
مثل أننا مزق